[Musique]
y'a pas ce terme j'essaie toujours de
m'imaginer ce qui est arrivé à ces gens
réunis au 6e et les nuits
[Musique]
je sors seul dans les bois je ferme les
yeux
j'essaie d'entendre les sirènes les
explosions
j'ai essayé de réaliser ce qu'ils ont
traversé de comprendre si je pourrais
vivre dans ces circonstances vous filmer
les arbres imaginer la quantité de gens
tout en bis si tous en même temps
en un instant ils sont tous tombés ou on
ne peut pas être sûr qu'il n'y a
personne ici qu'il n'y a pas un soldats
enterrés
on n'est pas sûr qu'il n'y ait pas un
soldats enterrés ici ou là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans ce cas il y à des fragments de
crâne et voilà un bras très bien prenait
des pics pour creuser la seconde guerre
mondiale a pris fin il ya 75 ans mais
des milliers de personnes sont portées
disparues
leurs corps étant enfouie dans les bois
les maires des marécages leurs familles
n'ont jamais su ce qui leur était arrivé
jusqu'à maintenant des gens attendent le
retour de leurs proches de la guerre et
il se trouve des hommes et des femmes
dévouées qui est des soldats revenir
chez eux
je suis venu ici pour la première fois
en 2010 ici il ya eu des combats
vraiment très sanglant des terres ont
été prises et d'autres ont été perdues
les combats était si intense que ni les
soldats russes ni allemands n'avaient le
temps d'enterrer leurs camarades
c'est la cinquième fois que nous faisons
des recherches et cet endroit et que
nous trouvons des corps voilà la seconde
semaine et alors pourquoi vous ne
croisez pas cela fait plus de trente ans
qu arthur all cops qui recherchent des
soldats portés disparus il a commencé
seul mais s'est ensuite mis invité des
écoliers
aujourd'hui son organisation de
recherche est l'une des plus importantes
de russie
lors de mon premier jour de travail
ma première expédition vous savez
j'espérais trouver au mieux une douille
venir de la chance mais nous avons
trouvé un corps entier les restes des
ossements les effets personnels
j'ai été bouleversé j'étais juste jeu
presque éclaté en sanglots c'est
vraiment incroyable que tant de soldats
soient enterrés ici dans les bois au
lieu d'être et chez eux avec leur
famille
je lai il ya une torpille à tribord et
sortons là d'accord
[Musique]
le 9 mai les gens se rendent sur les
tombes des soldats tués pendant la
grande guerre patriotique et déposent
des fleurs
personne ne vient sur les tombes des
marins qui sont morts en mer ce car ils
ont été coulés avec leurs navires
il repose sur les fonds marins c'est
pour cela qu'on a eu l'idée de rendre
hommage à la mémoire de ces marins pour
veiller sur leur mémoire en quelque
sorte
puis l'expédition initialement conçue
comme commémorative s'est transformé en
une équipe de recherche près oui
constantin bogdanov et son équipe
recherchent des sous marins dont la
seule mer baltique 24 sous marin
soviétique sont portées disparues hop
kanye osipov était l'un des sous
mariniers soviétique les plus connus de
la flotte de la baltique capitaine du
sous-marin ch tch 406 il a reçu la
médaille de héros de l'union soviétique
après sa toute première mission
osipov a coulé plusieurs navires ennemis
principaux fatah au caire en surface le
sous marin est prêt
[Musique]
en mai 1943 le ch tch 406 part pour sa
troisième mission avec 37 sous marines
et à bord il ne reviendra jamais
personne ne savait ce qu'il était devenu
ni où le chercher notre historien a
trouvé des documents finlandais selon
lesquelles quelques jours après le
naufrage du sous-marin
le corps d'un sous marinier en
combinaison sauvetage s'est échoué sur
une île au large des côtes finlandaise
il y a été enterré il a été impossible
d'établir son identité mais compte tenu
du courant de la rose des vents et du
trafic de sous-marins à ce moment il est
à 95% sûr que ce sous marinier était un
membre de l'équipage du cht ch 406 et
puisque nous connaissons l'endroit où le
corps s'était échoué nous avions une
idée du secteur où il fallait chercher
le sous marin
après plusieurs jours de recherches
l'équipe trouve enfin sous marin de
l'époque de la seconde guerre mondiale
mais ce n'est pas le sous-marin aussi
pauvre
[Musique]
ce sous-marin et d'une autre série il a
coulé en 1942
voilà c'est tout
[Musique]
sans nous avons trouvé un soldat en
juger par ses bottes
c'est un soldat soviétique car elles
sont retroussés vers le bas les
allemands n'avaient pas cette habitude
gym au sol tant il a dû mourir ici
encore et plein d'éclats d'obus
en 1945 il y a eu de féroces batailles
pour les auteurs de ce silo les troupes
soviétiques se rapprocher de berlin au
cours des combats plus de douze mille
soldats allemands ont été tués tandis
que l'armée rouge a perdu plus de 20
mille soldats
c'est là que se trouve la ligne de
trancher pour moi cela a commencé par
des recherches sur ce qui était arrivé à
mon grand père mon grand père paternel a
fait la guerre sur le front de l'est en
russie
il a combattu près de voronej
en tant que commandant de compagnie et
lieutenants il y est mort le 24
septembre 1942 l'intérêt que j'ai porté
au sort de mon grand père a eu une
grande influence sur moi cela m'a donné
envie de travailler dans ce domaine
lorsqu'en 1992 une équipe russe qui
recherchait des soldats portés disparus
a invité leurs collègues allemands à les
rejoindre
albrecht a accepté cette proposition ait
été l'un des premiers à se rendre en
russie
il a ensuite créé sa propre équipe pour
retrouver les soldats tombés en europe
de l'est aujourd'hui
son équipe est composé d'allemands de
néerlandais d'ukrainiens de suisse et de
russes les petits enfants d'anciens
ennemis travaillent ensemble oui mon ami
pour le moment il n'y a qu'un calmes
étrangement la tête et séparée du corps
la tranchée est orienté vers les russes
donc c'est très probablement un allemand
bref nous invitait à participer à sa
traditionnelle expédition en 2010 nous
sommes venus ici pour la première fois
depuis nous venons travailler dans les
tranchées déterrer les soldats qui se
trouve près de la surface
si je retrouve un soldat c'est un
événement qui a beaucoup d'importance et
de signification pour moi je suis très
ému je veux vraiment le déterrer moi
même je veux que le soldat soit
identifié qu'il y ait une sorte
d'artefacts je ne sais pas une plaque
d'identité militaire des médailles ou
autre chose qu'on puisse trouver des
parents pour qu'on puisse l'enterrer le
sort du soldat est probablement la chose
la plus importante dans nos recherches
en quatre jours de travail dans un champ
près de saint pétersbourg
les volontaires ont déjà retrouvé 50
soldats mais jusqu'à présent seules
quelques personnes ont été identifiées
[Musique]
vous aussi vous avez de la chance il ya
une plaque d'identité
oui vous le nôtre et je suis sous le
choc bouleversé qu'est-ce qui pourrait
plus important qu'est-ce qui pourrait
plus important maria est très excitée
parce qu'ils ont trouvé une plaque
d'identité soviétique
elle peut contenir le nom du soldat sa
ville d'origine et parfois les
coordonnées de sa famille
les capsules de ce type doivent être
ouvertes avec précaution pour éviter
d'endommager le papier qui se trouve à
l'intérieur
si le nom est lisible ils pourront
retrouver les proches du soldat
c'est le plus important
hier deux personnes ont été identifiées
maintenant on vient de m'apporter une
troisième plaque d'identité
toutes les trois ont été retrouvés dans
un site de fouilles et de soldats
retrouvés hier viennent de l'altaï il
était peut-être ensemble ils se sont
peut être enrôlé ensemble et sont morts
ensemble voilà troisièmes que laitiers
[Musique]
c'est serré tu
il est notre chance est écrit au crayon
très bien
[Musique]
wolverine même mieux que dimitri c'était
panneaux beach comme né en 1904
tirailleurs altaï je dis toujours que la
chose la plus difficile dans notre
travail c'est en fait il ne suffit pas
de trouver un soldat de trouver sa
plaque d'identité de l'ouvrir et de lire
la note
parfois ça prend des décennies de
trouver des proches
[Musique]
quand pape a rejoint l'armée
je n'avais que deux ans j'étais tout
petit
il m'a porté dans ses bras puis ils sont
tous montés dans la voiture
il sont partis c'est ce que maman
racontait qu on a reçu un avis de décès
ils étaient portés disparus
c'est tout porté disparu au début on a
attendu surtout quand notre voisin est
revenue maman disait peut-être qu'il
reviendra aussi peut-être qu'il est
vivant mais il n'est jamais revenu
tiken gorbatchev était l'un des soldats
récemment retrouvé près de smolensk
il a été identifié grâce à sa plaque
d'identité et on a immédiatement
commencé à rechercher ses proches sur
les réseaux sociaux
mon arrière petit fils a vu cette
annonce sur internet
l'union il a été retrouvé
cela fait soixante dix huit ans je
n'avais plus d'espoir bien vous voyez
[Musique]
valentina a demandé aux volontaires de
ramener le corps de son père chez elle
et de l'enterrer à côté de sa mère qui a
attendu le retour de son mari toute sa
vie ne perdons pas espoir qu'il
reviendrait un jour
la part
[Musique]
et de petite taille
je voudrais vous transmettre ce dossier
ici il y à sa plaque d'identité et la
note adressée à votre maman votre papa
l'a écrite
voilà cette bonne note et la capsule
dans laquelle on l'a trouvé la capsule
est ici ou les garder la merci
infiniment que les enfants six arrière
petits enfants puisse la lire
[Musique]
l'équipe de constantin bogdanov poursuit
la recherche du sous-marin ch tch 406 il
utilise un sonar pour explorer les fonds
marins du golfe de finlande
un sous-marin de plus
[Musique]
les premiers plongeurs on pensait que
c'était le n96 un autre sous-marin que
tout le monde essaie de trouver quand
j'ai plongé
j'ai vu un massif typique certaines
caractéristiques de conception et j'ai
compris que c'était le sous-marin dos
hip hop en plus on a trouvé une
écoutille du massif ouverte ce qui
confirme parfaitement la théorie selon
laquelle un sous marinier avait quitté
le sous-marin donc tout concordait
c'était un sentiment incroyable bien sûr
on a trouvé le sous-marin d'aussi
peuvent aussi pauvre
oui le 406 le 4 106 ch tch 406 a heurté
une mine sous marine allemande
l'équipage était très expérimenté ils
sont restés très calmes n'ont pas
paniqué et on sait y ait de quitter le
sous marin et au moins certains d'entre
eux ont réussi malheureusement ni la
profondeur ni la position du sous marin
dont l'essai l'équipage beaucoup de
chance de survie en fait
aussi étrange que cela puisse paraître
le sous marinier qui a réussi à sortir
qui est mort c'est son corps qui nous a
amenés dans cette zone
il était comme un phare indiquant qu'il
fallait chercher ici
[Musique]
chaque fois que nous nous rendons sur un
tel site il ya des mouettes
quoi qu'on fasse elles sont là
d'habitude leur nombre est égal à celui
des sous mariniers
nous avons annoncé qu'un sous marin
avait été retrouvé et identifié comme le
ch tch 406 et nous revenions chez nous
c'est à dire sur le continent à
saint-pétersbourg une tempête a éclaté
et nous avons changé de route pour ne
pas couler nous nous sommes arrêtés à
primorsk
et à 5 6 heures du matin on a vu un
homme sur la jetée qui a dit je suis
denis osipov j'ai commencé à me dire
qu'elle aussi pauvre il ya la même
apparence
je suis resté pétrifié nous nous sommes
présentés il s'est avéré que c'était son
petit neveu et la veille il avait pris
la relève au service de contrôle
portuaire et son patrouilleur était à un
navire de distance de nous nous avons
donc quasiment accoster sur lui quand
j'étais petit ma mère m'a dit qu'un de
nos parents evgeny osipov avait disparu
avec son sous marin
[Musique]
les gardes-frontière m'ont dit qu'il
existait une équipe qui recherchait des
sous marins je ne savais pas qu'il avait
déjà trouvé
je savais qu ils le cherchaient quand je
les ai vus devant moi j'ai senti que
c'était le destin
ce n'est pas par hasard que la tempête
les amener vers moi il fallait que ça
ait lieu
depuis l'enfance je fais un rêve lors
duquel a lieu une explosion et je me
réveille sans comprendre ce qui se passe
depuis qu'ils ont trouvé le sous marin
je ne fais plus ce rêve
[Musique]
asseyez vous vous voulez du thé ou du
café
je veux bien du café avec du sucre à
sucre mireille taurine vivait à
leningrad lorsque la guerre a éclaté il
s'est enrôlé comme volontaire et a fait
partie de ceux qui essayait de briser le
siège
il a été blessé à plusieurs reprises
mais il retournait toujours au combat
sa famille se trouvait à leningrad il se
battait pour ses projets il y avait de
violents combats ici les allemands tirer
en permanence jour et nuit
nuit et jour sans arrêt chaque aube lui
tu es une ou deux personnes ont parlé à
quelqu'un et cinq minutes plus tard il
était mort c'était difficile de
s'habituer à cela on est dans une
tranchée quelque part les avions
arrivent dans le bombardement commence
[Musique]
quand c'est fini on regarde autour de
soi
celui ci est mort celui là aussi celui
ci est blessé celui là a perdu ses
jambes
j'ai eu de la chance vous savez j'ai été
blessé cinq fois j'ai eu de la chance
j'ai été blessé à la jambe au cou et
ailleurs dans le dos aussi non
[Applaudissements]
c'est
imaginez nous sommes sous un feu nourri
quelqu'un se fait tuer on rentre sous
son corps on le met sur soi il est mort
et il me sauve la vie
[Musique]
on
et
oh
ja je ne sais pas ce que j'aurais fait à
la place de ces soldats de ces
infirmières
c'est très dur on ne peut pas s'y
préparer et tue tous ses tirs ces bombes
c'est tellement effrayant je n'arrive
pas après un dessin pleinement
on
nous devons préparer l'enterrement
préparer les corps des soldats
soviétiques pour le transfert on les
enterre pas immédiatement on les laisse
comme ça nous allons mettre les corps
marqué en bleu dans les cercueils le
préparons les dépouilles des soldats
allemands pour l'enterrement
ce sont les restes des soldats tombés au
combat que nous avons récupérés dans les
tranchées ici à clé sin l'année dernière
et cette année c'est chat son gré 7662
c'est un soldat d'infanterie heinrich
bof
mettons cela sur le côté ici ou là à
gauche ou à droite tant apporté
nous avons la chance d'avoir pu établir
l'identité de quatre soldats
les autres restent pour l'instant
inconnues on enterre des soldats tombés
au combat
quelle que soit leur nationalité dans le
pays où ils ont été retrouvés lors des
expéditions internationales
il existe une autre règle si des
allemands trouvent un soldat et
comprennent qu'ils les soviétiques il
invite les volontaires russes à le
déterrer et les russes invite les
allemands a déterré leurs soldats les
groupes de recherche des différents pays
ont longtemps été capable de retrouver
une langue commune
contrairement aux hommes politiques
profonds en pologne
nous sommes presque considérés comme des
envahisseurs pareil en lettonie
ils créent des obstacles supplémentaires
à notre travail en raison de certains
problèmes politiques mais pour moi c'est
tous les soldats doivent être enterrés
nous n'oublions pas qu'ils ont
traversées non seulement notre
territoire mais aussi la pologne
l'allemagne la lettonie
tout comme la lituanie où il est
interdit de creuser je sais qu'il y à
des soldats on me les a montrés mais on
ne peut pas les récupérer
chacun a ses préjugés
son expérience peut-être que certaines
personnes ont été exposées une influence
négative des médias ou à une autre
influence t lorsque des équipes de
recherche de différents pays travaillent
ensemble
cela aide à comprendre les problèmes des
uns et des autres à devenir amis dit
peut-être que les relations comme celle
que nous entretenons contribueront à
faire en sorte que l'histoire ne se
répète pas et à permettre aux nations de
vivre dans l'amitié et d'envisager un
avenir meilleur que celui de ceux qui
ont souffert et sont morts dans ces
champs il ya 70 ans
[Musique]
il semble qu'il n'ait plus de chaussures
je veux dire probablement ils ont pris
ses bottes en feutre louis la 77e
division de fusiliers de lagarde qui a
pris que les cils d'après les munitions
qu'il possède le badge de la garde le
badge de tireurs soviétique et l'absence
d'un grand nombre de marques
distinctives typique des soldats de la
wehrmacht leçon strauss ça doit être un
soldat de l'armée rouge
il doit être enterré l'année prochaine
au mémorial de guerre dans la ville de
lebu ce pas loin d'ici
c'est là que sont enterrés tout ce que
nous trouvons ici
ce n'est pas le dernier je pense qu'il y
en aura beaucoup d'autres
[Musique]
récemment j'ai trouvé cet album avec de
vieilles photographies de 1928 sur celle
là c'est mon grand père mon arrière
grand père et le frère de mon grand père
evga ni osipov je suis capitaine du
sous-marin ch tch 406 denis osipov
perpétue cette dynastie de marins à bord
du brise-glace semionov genève la
rencontre avec l'équipe de recherche a
changé sa vie une rencontre remarquable
des gens merveilleux
ils n'ont tout raconté ils m'ont montré
des vidéos de leurs recherches et je
leur ai demandé de me laisser me joindre
à leur équipe
[Musique]
aujourd'hui aussi poste nous accompagne
donc en tant que membre de l'équipe lors
de la première expédition ma tâche
consistait à aider les autres à mettre
leurs équipements à les aider à sortir
de l'eau c'est difficile il faut retirer
des bonbonnes d'oxygène lors de la
deuxième expédition je m'occupais de la
cuisine à la cambuse que le chef après
le capitaine occupe la deuxième position
c'est une petite régression pour lui il
s'est avéré être très utile il a
commencé son travail au sein de notre
équipe quand on a trouvé le sous-marin
de son grand oncle j'ai décidé de
continuer à chercher les sous marins
disparus avec mes camarades
ma tâche est de plonger dans le ch tch
406 d'y jeter un coup d'oeil
c'est pour cela que je plonge parfois on
dit que je suis trop zélé je prends des
risques
[Musique]
malheureusement ma profonde de records
n'est que de 15 m mais je m'entraîne dur
je veux y arriver le plus vite possible
surtout que j'ai déjà 50 ans passés elle
l'a plongée est une chose très compliqué
même pour de jeunes organisés bref
j'essaye de réaliser ce que je désire
tant plongez dans le sous marin et
l'inspecter
[Musique]
je le répète les gars il est beaucoup
plus facile de creuser avec des pics
qu'avec une telle note en 2000 on m'a
posé la question suivante combien de
temps je pouvais vous faire seul art et
un scanner j'ai dit que j'avais un fils
il avait six mois j'espérais vraiment
qu'il n'irait pas en expédition avec moi
à cette époque je serais déjà mais voilà
aujourd'hui la 18 ans et il vient avec
moi depuis qu'il a 12 ans quand je suis
venu pour la première fois j'avais 12
ans je ne peux pas dire que je
comprenais ce qu'il se passait à
l'époque il est même avant je m'y
intéresser parce que mon père aller
quelque part ils revenaient pas raser
fatigué met de bonne humeur
alors voilà à 12 ans je ne comprenais
encore rien et ce n'est que maintenant
que je commence à comprendre ce que je
fais la compréhension de ce qu'ont fait
n'arrive pas tout de suite
personne ne m'avait alors expliqué que
c'étaient des héros être là c'est déjà
un grand exploit en grèce
je n'y pensais pas de cette façon à
l'époque mais je trouve cela effrayant
aujourd'hui quand je commence à y
réfléchir
lorsque nous travaillons nous avons le
destin de ces personnes entre nos mains
a encore manqué ou perdre quelque chose
arrêter de creuser trop tôt ça c'est un
problème
[Musique]
sigoignet aujourd'hui grâce aux équipes
de recherche
nous avons l'occasion d'enterrer les
dépouilles de 109 héros de la grande
guerre patriotique
le mouvement de recherche en russie
compte plus de 42 mille volontaires qui
se donnent à fond de ménage ni leur
temps ni leurs efforts se rendent sur
les sites pour y travailler
en six ans nous avons récupéré les corps
de 120 mille soldats mais il en reste
beaucoup ont dit que la guerre n'est pas
terminée tant que le dernier soldat
n'est pas enterrée il me semble que le
dernier soldat de cette guerre ne sera
jamais enterré mais nous avons une
réelle opportunité de mettre au moins
fin à la guerre sous marine en mer
baltique
ils ont donné leur vie pour tous
aujourd'hui j'essaie de le rendre
hommage
j'ai deux grands pères portées disparues
je vois mon grand-père dans chaque
soldat
[Musique]
ils doivent tous être enterré ce qu'ils
ont fait c'est au delà des mots nous
vivons aujourd'hui dans notre pays nous
parlons notre langue nous vivons nos
vies
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]